personally
i can't get enough of award season i
love the opportunity to celebrate
people's work and accomplishments i love
how recognition like this can open doors
that weren't open before they can
inspire change so for you personally
what does award season mean to you why
is this time of year so special for the
industry
what it means to me and why it's special
to the industry are two i think very
different things
i i i concur
with you with regard to
it's it's wonderful
that actors get recognition for what
what they have done
it's unfortunate that
i think it's important that it not
become a competition
even though on some level we aren't
competing and that's
the unfortunate part but i would say
that certainly from the standpoint of
giving actors recognition that's
absolutely tremendous and i you know i'm
a member of the academy
and so many many years during award
season i i
oftentimes i get to watch
extraordinary work
excuse me and that's um
[Music]
really really you know gratifying
rewarding
inspiring to see the depth
and the breadth the magnitude
of the talent that's out there and on
and on display
kind of gotta be frank about this last
one here because
the golden globes are on my mind we're
recording this interview the day after
the ceremony
so what go i know what went mutt through
my mind when i heard the nominations
what goes through your mind when there's
so much positivity and buzz and support
behind you
and then not only your personal
nomination
but the five bloods is nowhere to be
found
in that nomination list because like it
hurt me
i can't even imagine how it made you and
the team feel
it reminded me
that certain pockets of the industry
certain pockets of this process are
still a business
and it being a business
the connection between the business
and the creative aspect do not always
align and i was reminded of that
very starkly very acutely
in that moment that the
uh nominations for the golden globes
were announced what is
something actionable that you think
folks in the industry could do
to change that even when it's not in an
or it's not an organization that you're
necessarily a part
of i always think it's worthwhile
talking about the possibilities to at
least spark that change
right and again i think that is an
entirely
legitimate question um
it's very difficult for me to answer
that question
this year as it as it relates to the
golden globes
because i feel that anything that i say
will be seen as sour grapes perhaps
and i'm not trying to set myself up to
be
assessed in that regard you know
interestingly perhaps if you
if i were not so directly involved in
awards season
this year and on another year i might be
able to answer that
more quote unquote objectively um
but having said that i would say that
i i hope it is being looked at not just
in terms of
me because the fact is as you know if
you're an award season
fan you know that every single year
there are worthy performances that get
ignored
i mean the thing and i'm not maybe i'll
get in trouble for saying this but i
cannot understand at all
how alfred woodard's work last year in
clemency
was not lauded
uh more widely every year
it happens that there are worthy
performances that
for whatever reason don't get the
recognition
so as it relates to this year
i think this year is particularly
egregious
and i think and i can only hope
that that process is deconstructed
and looked into because if you're going
to call yourself a legitimate
awards giving organization
then
how are you functioning what are you
recognizing and why
now they may say well we don't have to
answer that question and you're right
you don't
you don't quote unquote oh me or perhaps
anybody else there
but when um
it involves such a seemingly
blatant
um non-reaction
if you were hurt as a as as an observer
i really should stop because
um i i just think you asked a legitimate
question
i think it is a legitimate question to
say
okay what's what's going on here what's
really going on here
and smarter minds than myself will
perhaps answer that question or
investigate that